My oncologist has told me at least five visits that my MRI results would probably be better if I would just take to
Moxifit. I listened to your videos regarding that drug and chose to take them. You sell. I take two caps a day.
Do you think that's equivalent to taking the drug?
No, I don't think it's equivalent. I don't think there is a natural equivalent to taking to Moxifit, which is an aromatics inhibitor, which effectively completely shuts off all your estrogen all your hormones.
So there isn't a natural way to do an aromatase inhibitor as well as the drug will do it. And that's why so many women would choose to go the natural way, because they don't want the same exact effects negative effects that would happen if you took the drug.
Right, if you just want to shut off all your hormones, why don't you just take the drug? Well, because I don't want to shut off all my hormones. I just want to shut off.
I don't want to shut down all my estrogen and all my progesterone and all my testosterone and I just feel like horrible and I have all these symptoms. I don't want to do that.
Okay, well, then if there's not going to be a natural thing that's going to do that as well, if there was, you might as well just take the drug. So the effective demand and so for a faint and icy three and different products that are natural aromatase inhibitors, it's going to be much more gentle. It's going to be milder.
So if your purpose is to really, really shut down all your estrogen in your body and really help with estrogen receptor progesterone receptor or who to positive cancers, then you just might as well take the medication.
But so many people choose not to do it that way, want to do it that way and can have you won't have the exact same effects, but you'll have the same or similar outcome. And that's the goal, right, you want to have the same outcome.
So the only way to know if you're going to have the same outcome is, unfortunately, through trial and error, that's just the way life is. We don't know unless you can show, let's say, let's say I'm going to do a natural approach. I'm going to take them and other natural aromatase inhibitors.
And then I do MRI in three months. And my cancer is worse that I can choose to do the to mocks if and I can choose to go a heavier route.
Well, why don't I just choose to do that first? Well, that's a choice of person, many people, most people do make. But then if that doesn't work, then they maybe done damage to their body and they have some regrets. So
it's kind of like my comment has been over the years of like, okay, should we just hit it hard and heavy, my cancer is heavy as I got, because that's many times you'll hear that.
And a collegeist will make that statement, you have this cancer, they'll give the diagnosis. And we're going to hit this with all we got to kill the cancer. And
well, I'm not saying that can't be effective. That's like saying we have a sniper in New York City. So we're going to nuke the whole city. There's going to be a lot of collateral damage to hit it hard and heavy, hit it with all we got.
There's going to be collateral damage that goes along with that. And are you willing? Is that collateral damage? That's not always even whether you're even willing to risk that or not. You got to look at is that wise. Sometimes it might be saying it's not. But is it wise for you? You're going to make that decision.